hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nostalgic games now
these are games that you probably played
if you existed on the Internet in the
last 20 years the the games that you
played in computer lab when you thought
the teacher wasn't looking or even if
the teacher was looking you didn't even
care I'm gonna start out with one that I
think is ubiquitous which just means if
I get to look up the definition of
ubiquitous present appearing or found
everywhere ubiquitous we're learning
today just like in school all that time
you were playing these games we got to
catch up somehow and an hacky probably
people are even playing him today but
I'm gonna start out with one that you
guys have played it wasn't even cleverly
named it's called helicopter game the
original lovingly made and and horribly
frame rated the maker and breaker of
every friendship in high school and
middle school and any other type of
school that you've ever had I haven't
played in I remember I remember first
discovering this and like oh oh
first discovering in like the first
computer lab class I had in school you
know I've been I've been working with
computers like since I was five years
old my dad he introduced me to computers
at a young young age but I didn't play
this one for a good while it is so
simple it's so simple because the
mechanic is so self-explanatory
the death is so sudden a lot of ways
it's kind of the precursor to flappy
bird weird I mean when it comes down to
a game mechanics aren't all that complex
so for 20 baby plays it's okay that's
embarrassing and so when it comes down
to like trying to make it comes down to
trying to make cool game mechanics there
is really not much innovation on it what
do you think so many games are you
holding the gun shooting baddies zombies
are such a pervasive theme what do you
think what do you think pokemons does so
well please give me some reason to give
me a self an excuse here
ah that didn't clip see it's unfair
games unfair right the hitbox isn't
right games Carmy
and yet I'm still playing why am I still
playing oh here we go
we're on a roll baby I got a shop
talking I can't shut up I want to get
over a thousand come on just saying -
shouting come and two's good to do we're
halfway there I just want to get to a
thousand in school and just suddenly
everyone's quietly working tip-top on
their keyboards and then you hear me in
the back one point my excuse for ah shut
up shut up me just I gotta shut up I'm
not gonna shut up here I go I'm gonna
prove that it's not talking that does me
in it's me I was talking about how my
finger is called cuz it's called in this
room and therefore my reaction times a
little slow it's not my fault it's the
game's fault
I made it like a knife through butter
like a helicopter through a weird cave
that we're going through and I hope this
isn't a search-and-rescue mission
because whoever's trapped in this caves
oh god oh god the distance yes
I'm keep going I don't know where this I
don't think it's fine okay so that is
helicopter game there's really no reason
to stress that hard about it and yet I
get super stressed about things that are
that child Mew was better at than hi
right now the second one I guarantee you
fled curveball baby boink
super curve bonus you can't get none of
this you suck dog you know I think
everybody in there in the entire school
system just wish that this was somehow
able to be played multiplayer and I'm
sure they've made like some VR version
of this but it'll never be the same it's
just like the the loving creation that
is the original curve
baby Thank You gabay may answer is
probably keep your computers it gets
unfairly good after a while Oh what I
was definitely over that analyze the
frames oh well that was definitely not
over that one huh there you go I only
got one left
nah too fast it's too fast it's too fast
oh jeez holy jeez um's it's very clearly
over that one's hard I don't need to
rage about it this is hard oh yeah I
played this out of this game I
totally forgot about it but the
mechanics of that just reminded me and
I'm gonna secret trick okay here's how
here's a business called spank the
monkey right there's a monkey is my hand
pretty pathetic spank right all right
now if you get a good wallop on him I
ruined it with mine my contribution it
was fine and then it wasn't fine so the
idea is just you you this Oh what the
hell
this has resulted in breaking what the
hell come on mom this is resulted in
breaking so many high school computer
lab mice cuz they just get flung as hard
as it okay well that's just a bunch of
baloney you know how to play shut up oh
why you son of a tip
whatever my second hit was great and
then I'm never able to repeat it okay
but that's okay
cuz everyone knows I or if you didn't
know then you're a scrub but you're a
spank the monkey scrub and you need to
get good everyone knows the proper way
to get maximum spank äj--
messed that one up okay hang on where my
mouse okay here's my mouse proper way to
get appropriate spank egde see what you
do is you click and drag and you hold it
and you can't see where your mouse is
but you just kind of feel out around the
outside of the box and then you enter in
as slowly as possible to get that last
pixel and then the the game thinks that
oh you're suddenly over there and it
registers it as a world-shattering spank
so you just try to get the yeah
absolutely
oh it's a bomb it's a bomb I've gotten
over 600 miles per hour once in my
history maybe maybe I'm remembering that
wrong but I'm pretty sure I did alright
so next up is a game that again probably
everybody played this is an interactive
buddy so interactive buddy oh this is
weird game where you get money from
playing around with this little dude
he's scared of me
come here I don't imagine why you would
be scared of me I get the hiccups I'm
good I'm good you just jostle him around
and he gets real happy about it and then
buy new items a wide nozzle hose rubber
balls goes in the hose that's good yeah
you are you you spray em down give them
a good showering well that doesn't give
me any money well they give me any money
I guess if he's on fire that would help
so uh oh yeah hold on
he's look oh Jesus how's that and now
he's scared of it that's funny is like a
rudimentary little thing cuz he's got
dynamic animations there's like lighting
shadows and then he gets knocked out and
then you just does a bunch of grenades
bang I feel more for you here we go he
not happy okay
Oh everybody rule of 's rubber balls
okay wait let's let's tickle him he ha
ha ha he likes it about rubber balls
Eagle rubber ball play with the rubber
ball look at him he's bopping him around
come on robber ball robber ball robber
ball robber ball how about bowling balls
you like um my boy boss no boy
ma'am he does not look good weak gravity
vortex balls
maybe balls were not the best idea I'd
hate to see what a strong gravity vortex
does now that is what I am talking about
all right well that's that's breaking my
computer huh something about flash games
just don't work well it's like our
minecraft still kind of garbage there we
go that's good though that's good you
like bowling balls I remember you like
bowling balls of these two things I
remember that you definitely like
bowling balls more keeping bowling ball
monsters Oh God boy hold on strong
gravity vortex I like that fire balls
Molotov exploded mouse stun gun
flamethrower Ford infants infants up put
the pile on bump that looks fun that
looks really fun
God blow him up first
it is babies moment Wow it's fun all
right one for good measure fireballs all
right
something tells me we didn't need more
than one fireball highway I have
something they can help out with this
right right all right all right oh you
want the oh here we go
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome well toasty baby's here there
you go there see aren't you dying are
you happier now that I put you out Ben
is making money somehow I don't know how
Oh cuz he keeps lighting the babies over
and over again a missile oh no boom boom
no there's one more game that I want to
show you now this isn't as old but it's
a cool game nonetheless this is sugar
sugar and sugar sugar is about drawing
sugar into a cup simple as that
couldn't be simpler it could be simpler
but it's not simpler couldn't possibly
be simpler and so you have these elegant
systems that you have to create which
allow you to get sugar into the cups
and that's it that's the whole thing
white sugar in the red cup red sugar in
the red cup color sugar send it through
the filter it's just so satisfying is
the thing a lot of these games are
purely about satisfaction getting the
things to go in drawing a line yourself
and I've gotten very good at drawing
lines with my mouse so what it amounts
to is just it's fun there's a hole in
the ground the segments I'm off there
segments some off there yi just like
that
it's so easy onion muted sugar for
everybody including me crap go there you
go but that is sugar sugar Oh
one way what if what is the what's the
crux of this one one oh god oh god oh
god oh no oh no oh no
well how's easy
come on sugar sugar okay so you're gonna
go there but Kankan colored become I can
oh it's just that easy
oh it's just that easy bb2 ha ha I need
it stop the time has come push the
button what does it button do Oh oh wait
hang on I don't know what the button did
ah I know what the button did poop oh if
this seems complicated it's really not
he's got a way for you get enough sugar
then draw a line to the cup uses Babu
seems to be working there we go
not bad okay I got a stopper I'll be
here all day there's a great game great
game so that is sugar sugar that is
nostalgic gems
good stuff over the old days of the time
when things were simpler when my webcam
didn't break all the time
that's alright now I'm not gonna be all
nostalgic like heavy about it it's
better back in my day now that games a
classic some games just worked because
game mechanics by themself
hold up to the test of time so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play these games for yourself
check them out in the description below
and if you want to help support the
channel click that join button check out
all the cool perks you get for being a
member thank you everybody so much for
being here and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]